some guys making water with cannabis oil
with the cdb is a part of CBD yeah yeah
and it says it will help me relax after
my sonic bombast torture stage every
night I'm sure will think I have drink
some less yeah well I know you've had
some problems with your knees I have
both new knees and never get them
replaced
yeah um yeah jumping off all those amps
I never knew I never heard the word
meniscus till my doctor said I had none
I have a tear Oh mine I just got a
stem-cell shots in it yesterday no
slight I have two brand-new knees and I
ain't dancing like the 25 year old Ted
Nugent put you're walking fine I'm doing
fine so I used to have a bad limp right
from that shuffle yeah yeah and now it
were both gone Steve Tyler was here from
Aerosmith he's got a new one he's got
one new one and he's thinking about
getting another one I have both the same
time yeah how long were you down for I
was walking the next morning so what do
they do exactly well they're going to
cut your knee open and they get a hammer
and a chisel and they pound out the old
[ __ ] and put in some metal stuff have
you ever seen this actually available
online you don't want to watch it if
you're gonna have it done it's brutal
but I had a good surgeon and it came out
good and the pain going onstage for so
many years since certainly since the
year 2000 with the Damn Yankees even
what year did you get it done mm what is
it 18 no 12 maybe so 12 years of pain
yeah no it was it was more nat but up
because I jumped off those [ __ ]
amplifiers Oh what kind of dirtbag was I
somebody should have said you have
meniscus well you know save your
meniscus you know Maynard Keenan the
lead singer tool right he blew his hip
out from just stomping on the ground
because the music I have a new record
called the music made me do it
the music made him do it this music made
Steve Tyler do when you get up there it
is a world unto itself it is out-of-body
his stream of consciousness you
yet you got to be careful because you
think you're invincible invincible on
that stage with my away that movie
invincible that you stranglehold best
use of my song ever but best you see
your song ever was Randy KOTOR coming
out to stranglehold in the UFC yeah
you're probably right yes I remember
that yes and in the Blackhawks in
Chicago every gigs for the 25-30 years
they play strain he came out to
stranglehold when he beat Tim Sylvia for
the UFC heavyweight title was severe
under car underdog and he came out and
the place went nuts and steroid says it
all here I come again a baby like a dog
in heat she's telling me by the clamor
baby I'd like to tear up the street I've
been smoking for so long I'm here to
stay
I've got you in a stranglehold [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of my way
well knocking awesome beginnings it's a
love song you getting excited it's a
love song the connection between
rock-and-roll guitarist and bowhunting
for most people is like a big stretch
just stretch it's like what are those
different galaxies yeah a different
universe